[Music]
who wants children
when the future is uncertain the
pandemic threatened everything
health jobs lifestyles
bad times for offspring expert want us
including on our show about a year ago
natalie
will birth rates really fall i'm sure
there will be some lockdown babies born
that as a major trend to affect future
fertility rates is extremely unlikely
and i would say yes birth rates are
going to fall
at least in the next few years or in the
next year
that was true in previous crises in the
wake of the global financial crisis for
example
far fewer children were born in the
united states
as the coronavirus shock now also
triggered a global baby crisis
or is the desire to have a child
stronger than the virus in the long run
[Music]
hello and welcome to our kobe 19 special
i'm monica jones in berlin and
today we revisit a topic we've covered
a few times in this pandemic and one
that's crucial to our survival as a
species
making babies and here's the first
surprise while
experts predicted a drop in birth rates
here in germany
we've seen a baby boom nearly 66
000 babies were born in march 2021 just
as the third wave kicked in
now that's the highest march birth rate
in 20 years
if we count back nine months we see that
those march 2021 babies were conceived
in july
2020 just when the first lockdown
measures were eased in germany
for more i'm joined by natalie nietzsche
deputy head of the laboratory
for fertility and well-being at the max
planck institute in rostock and we've
talked about this topic before good to
see you again
uh what do we know a year later well
that's the theme of this week's cov19
special and the whole birth rate
story certainly seems to be taking a
different direction than expected you
certainly expected that birth rates will
fall and now we see a baby boom
what's changed yeah hello you're
absolutely right
we're seeing a baby boom across many
european countries right now for the
march birth
the data has just come out but the story
is quite
dynamic and i think in a way we were all
right
so the the development of the birthplace
across
the country that we have data from which
is mainly europe north america and some
asian countries
is quite dynamic and most countries have
seen a baby bust
during the birth months of say november
to january february so
the the decline in the birth rate we
predicted certainly
arrived but now there are many countries
that have um
actually an increase that's true
so so basically during uh the lockdown
periods not
much happened sitting on top of each
other
doesn't seem to be conducive to romance
then
well during the lockdown periods there
were much fewer birth conceived than
would have been expected compared to the
birth rate before
pretty much across all europe besides
perhaps scandinavia and germany there
were quite some declines so for example
south europe spain italy france portugal
they have seen
drops in the birth rate of 10 to 15 20
during these winter months birth that
would have been or work on
uh conceived during uh during the first
lockdown and now
the the births that were postponed are
catching up a little bit but not
not in all countries so you know
what is funny about research on health
bearing behavior is that we do know
a lot about what happens as soon as we
get the data
where their birth yes or no but why
that's often a different question and
quite complex to answer
romans during lockdowns yeah good
question and i wish i had the answer
um but uh there are first studies
well we can talk about that we can yeah
we can we can we can try
and and maybe second guess because what
you said i mean
uh there was a birth rate bust uh
certainly
uh in the months that were connected to
the lockdowns
and now the whole of europe seems to
experience higher birth rates
this spring which means if you look back
nine months that brings us to mid-summer
that's when europe more or less
opened up again as soon as the lockdowns
were east nine months later
we see more babies is there a pattern
absolutely this is the pattern we know
from crisis literature
uh and former times adjusts the
inconceptions and then following burst
during crises and the catching up so the
verse that were postponed
will then happen and the conceptions a
few months or years later depending on
when the crisis eases
uh what is interesting about this is
that we really can go month by month and
we can
now follow how the waves and the easing
of the lockdowns and the virus activity
has kind of affected the the conceptions
um you know what i wanted to say about
the romans during the lockdowns is quite
interesting because demographers have of
course speculated that the economic
uncertainty that the crisis has brought
would lead people to postpone
conceptions
and first studies we don't know much yet
but first studies indicate that really
the
emotional factors stress worries
mattered quite a bit for how people
made their plans about having a baby now
or postponing so those
who were worried about the economic
uncertainty
uh and who had relationship stresses for
example for studies show that these
people
were the ones who postponed
the the baby decision yeah but now we've
been
through several waves and we have all
learned the lesson that uh
the end of one wave doesn't mean that
the crisis is over but that the next
wave can be around the corner and maybe
another one after that
what will be the result there for
couples and their wish for having kids
will they just get used to the crisis
and say well let's go through with it
anyway
or will that put them off in the long
run
yeah let's speculate a little bit here i
think we will see a variety of dynamics
first partnering was disrupted so i
think uh
the partners that didn't find each other
perhaps during the first lockdown we
will see these effects later in some
declines and
i also expect the second wave to
lead to baby busts again specifically in
the countries that didn't see the busts
during the first wave conceptions like
germany netherlands scandinavia because
they were hit harder by the second wave
and i think this is still
causing a bust later on but i also think
many people are now vaccinated and we've
seen that the virus is
dangerous for everyone but certainly the
risk is concentrated in the older age
groups
so perhaps couples will not make their
decision dependent so much anymore on
their worries about the virus and health
and so on in the future
all right we have half a minute so a
short answer if you could
uh will the world population be bigger
or smaller after this pandemic
oh well temporarily it will shrink
fertility
falls mortality was high longevity was
cut off for some people
but i think in the very long run the
longer
trend dynamics we've seen the fall and
world fertility rates will probably
continue and
the pandemic may lead to temporary
distortions
but perhaps not long effects
all right natalie nietzsche their
fertility expert at the max planck
institute in rostock
thank you so much
thank you
clearly a lot has changed since last
year for one we have vaccines to help us
fight the pandemic and now
we've passed the three billion mark
worldwide we're getting there
now we know there's an issue in some
countries about pregnant women being
vaccinated
but what about young mothers time for
one of your questions
and over to derek
can i get a covered 19 vaccine if i'm
breastfeeding my baby
getting a clear answer to this question
has been an exercise in frustration for
new mothers and i
totally get why because authorities have
kind of
danced around the subject the cdc
in the u.s for example says that because
lactating women weren't part of studies
it can't make a concrete prediction
on any effects that vaccination might
have
on mothers their milk or their newborns
but the agency also adds that there are
no indications that breast milk from
vaccinated mothers
poses a risk to their babies and and
that women
therefore can receive a vaccine
so an answer that places the
responsibility for making the decision
squarely back on the shoulders of those
women and the doctors who advise them
many experts expect a firmer official
stance in the coming months
as as results from targeted studies roll
in but until then um here's a breakdown
of what the data indicates so far
first of all there's no evidence that
vaccines
harm breastfeeding mothers specifically
and
directly in any way and a growing pile
of evidence
that they protect them from covid19
as effectively as they protect other
people
second research into authorized
messenger rna vaccines hasn't found
any traces of them in breast milk in
lactating mothers um there's less data
on
other types of vaccines but experts say
even if traces of vaccine did make it
that far
they'd be broken down by a baby's
digestive system
when it swallows the milk what
researchers are detecting
in the breast milk of vaccinated mothers
is a lot of antibodies to stars kovi too
which isn't a surprise since mother's
milk
doesn't just nourish a baby but it also
plays a key role
in in protecting it from a range of
potentially
dangerous pathogens in the early crucial
stages of
development all in all the evidence
in favor of breastfeeding mothers
receiving vaccines
is growing stronger by the day and a lot
of experts
now recommend it but it still lacks
a blanket seal of approval from major
health care authorities
[Music]
and of course apart from being protected
from a severe case of kovit 19
vaccination also opens the door to more
activities
if you want to visit a bar or restaurant
in moscow you need to get a qr code to
prove
you've been vaccinated but only about 15
percent of the russian capital citizens
have been vaccinated
and many are hesitant to do so and
that's led to a new black
market prosecutors say websites are
offering
fake qr codes they don't come cheap
whereas vaccination is free
but with moves underway to extend the
need for codes to shopping centers and
public transit
demand is growing
and hopefully leading to more people
getting vaccinated and not
fake qr codes that's all for this
edition of kobit 19 special
thanks for watching stay safe